LIGH BU  DSEFNE TONIGHT. AT SCT
HIS
THOTIGHTWHEREE' A S ATC WORKSIT.
MASKS AREOPONAL DIT. YOU CAN
TH INTENTIONALLYOUTING HIS
GU THARINGS ITHIS POINT TE SPREE
36 STALUEE.ND
REPORTGD NUMBER OF
IN CALIRNTAZAS ARET A TIMEIG D
SA SAV GNEOPLE CANNOT MAINTAIN
PH
FACTEIRCUMSTANCES
ARE SUCH THATHO HAPPO MAT W SARG
ONE,KE
Y THIS.
>>NG TO MORUSHMO JULY 3rd
'RHAVE A FIREWKS
DIYE HAVE
SERE COMINGACF
LYNGTON, D.OR
UR RESIDENTS NOT TO ATOR THTH I
T IN THE
SO THIS ISN'T DO IRY ANYMORE
TH WSEO LIC HH IS, IF Y WSHOULD
JOE IS
SHORTLY.
ON THEUN
PNT ALWAYS
PRESIDENT TRIES TOART THE COUNT.
IF YOU LTOWER
LEVE H IN THEATMU UP.
WE HAVE BEENING A NOIL
PPEN.
AS YOU SAID, THEY'500INT IS T.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN A LOT OF FACE
EING
INE EN
LONG.
WE KNOW THA CIN
NOE GOVERNMENY WILL PROVI FMEN
G FOR
THAT. T THIRD ISSUE I
OF THIS ATKOTA, THAT WOULD AN
THAT ISAUSE A
BLACKDING CHAIRS FILLI ITH
AMPHHEEDETHER ZIP TI
ANEARTH WOD  SITUA
WHSON SITTISE A UP
EXPERIEN WGN IN THE
ERE IS A
THERE IS A F C HAVE TO HERE IS
EXAN HARDOR GET OUT. THING IS FN
THTI
S TOU
>>, THANK BREAKING GHATEATN INGF
PAMELA, THIS IS ALSOAUNG NG ATG.
AGENTS HAVGROUND INOTAOR PHEESE
THEY'RE ALSO PRI
PE TNE OF AT AS ONEREHEVIRUS.
WHEN Y LOOKT WS
THECSERVICE,AVE JED  EIGHT SECR
AGENTS N AT
P P F
CORONAVIPENCE'SRITHERE,
AND T FLU
KETOMS, A SE TLS M YION TO5  WH
POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS APRID ,
RECALL JUST
WEEKS.
COUPLEEN
SEAGENTS,
HAVE ALREADYE HE OS
ONEOUE TO JAMIE SAID THERE'S
A SENSEIOAM AGENTST THINUNNECTH
A WKESPERSONAYS
THE PRESIDENT S HE O T TVE THE
S A
UTKATE.
ME, THE BACIT'S G
>> Reporter: TO SEE YOU.
>UT WITH
RI DR.IAMAN OFFICIAL.
T SEE. TD ME LAST NIGHT
PRESIDENT TRUMSIRTING WITHASTERE
EAR N' ABOUT SECRET
SERVICEVIAG  TALK ABOECAUSEHJO
A CONCERNHE AND
HIEAM.
KATE,E AET
TOEROU YOULEE
WOULDT  DAU IN OCO R
TAM
YOUR THEY UR WN'T EVEN IN Y
HA
HAVE A MASSICIS WSEEVENTS THAT E
OMOTE TRGEUM
TH THIS DANGER PEOPLE T
SUPPORT AND IT'S A D
DHIM, ON THE MOFFERSON, ANDE OUL
ROM THE
PR A SELFISH A. ACTTION WHICH H
MESPLE TPPORT HIM
IT DR. THE OHE CONCERNSURUNHIS
LA THINK THAVE DONE A
NUMBERS MITAT
SPREAD O
AS YOU PBA O S MTE THESE VT OTHV
I THINK WE'RE V OF
E
REMAINED LOW. >> HE SAVE DONE TS
T OAND NOOCAN HELPE OF
TH
WEARING  NO SIS IS NOTOL
STRIKESUT PHORS, THIS
PROFESSOR WILL MARKHA
ONT.
FOR SURE STATISTICALLY,D WL ATTD
TOTHS.
IT WILL BE SPPLE HOME AND